Good morning all when we left today's lecture,
I have called,
as you can see,
uh,
the mother of all forums,
civic architecture in Rome under Trajan.
And I think you'll see what I mean.
Uh,
when we look both at a transgenic bath building and also the forum of Trajan in
Rome.
What I mean by mother of all forums,
these war or were Gargantuan buildings bigger than anything that we have seen
before.
And interesting in all kinds of ways.
We left off with Nerva with the emperor nerva and you'll recall that nerva was
old and in fact also relatively sickly,
uh,
when he became emperor of Rome.
You'll also remember,
and I remind you of his portrait on the lefthand side of the screen,
you'll also recall that he was a member of the Senate and that he was chosen by
the Senate,
uh,
one of their own to become emperor of Rome,
the first emperor to come from the senatorial ranks in the history of Rome.
Uh,
but B,
because he,
and he was very popular with the Senate,
but nerva recognized quite early on that although he was popular with the Senate
and with the aristocracy,
uh,
he was not a favorite of the army.
Uh,
and he realized that was not a good position to be in.
And so he wisely decided very early on that he would select the most popular
military man and the most highly successful military man in Rome,
a man by the name of Trajan as his heir.
And so nerva adopts Trajan a new see Trojans portrait on the right hand side of
the screen.
Nerva adopts Trajan in 97,
a d so that in 98 when nerva dies because he dies after only 16 months in office
when Nerva dies,
Trajan succeeds him without contest.
Trajan was an extraordinary emperor for Rome.
Uh,
there are a number of important points about trades and that should be made,
uh,
that have an impact on our understanding and analysis of his architecture.
One of those is he's the first Roman emperor to be born outside of Italy.
He was born in Spain,
the first emperor board in Spain.
That's not to say that Spain was the Boondocks by any stretch of the
imagination.
They had already been colonized by Rome and was very highly developed with
regard to its civilization.
He also came to power as a relatively young man.
He was only 45 years of age,
couple of years younger than Obama.
Uh,
and consequently he was in very,
and he was in very good physical shape.
Uh,
and so he had the physical wherewithal to be the kind of energetic emperor that
Rome needed.
At this particular point,
he undertook many military campaigns and very successfully,
and he was the emperor that Rome to its furthest reaches to its greatest
borders.
It's most extensive borders,
uh,
during his reign.
Uh,
and actually these were borders that were never gone beyond.
after this point we'll see that the emperor Hadrian consolidates,
uh,
the extent of the empire as reached by Trajan and no one ever takes it beyond
that.
So this is going to be the furthest extent of the Empire that we'll see in the
course of the semester.
And he was also extremely wise when it came to his choice of the kinds of
buildings that he wanted to put up because he followed in the footsteps of
Vespasian and Titus by favoring major public architecture in Rome.
And by a shooing a private architecture.
He wanted above all to disassociate himself from a neuro and from demission who
had favored palatial architecture as you'll recall.
And so he,
he builds public architecture in Rome,
uh,
and uh,
lies himself in this regard to such earlier emperors as Augustus,
uh,
and as,
as,
uh,
Claudius and as the Flavian Dynasty.
And we're going to see that in his building projects today.
Like so many other emperors,
uh,
when he came first came to power,
he looked around to see which buildings had fallen into disrepair,
uh,
and he decided to restore as many of those as he could.
And he chose very carefully.
Again,
he obviously did not choose buildings of a neuro,
uh,
many of which had already been destroyed in any case of it.
Rather look back further,
in fact,
dug deep into the republic a time,
a simpler time in many respects.
And a time prior to the shenanigans of the more monarchical minded emperors like
Nero and just Vespasian Nero and Domitian,
excuse me.
Uh,
and he restored buildings from the Republican from the Augusta period.
and he looked back,
for example,
to the forum of Caesar in Rome,
the forum,
you Liam,
which you all know,
uh,
well,
and we've talked about it before and I'm not going to discuss it in any detail
today,
just to remind you that it began to be restored.
That is the form of Julius Caesar under demission and that that restoration was
completed by trade and some at some point during his reign between 98 and 117 a
d and I remind you of that here,
you'll recall its location right next to the victory monument,
Victor Emmanuel Monument in Rome.
A you'll remember that even though it was restored by demission and Trajan,
uh,
it has fallen on hard times.
And if you look at the temple of Venus Ghana tricks,
I,
you see that all that survives besides the podium and the staircase are three
columns from that restored version by Trajan.
Uh,
you see the same three columns over here and then you'll recall the great open
space with colonnades on either side and then the market area,
the shops,
or to bear nigh on the left.
I showed you this view as well,
uh,
pointing out one of the architectural blocks,
that belonged to the restored building,
the building under Trajan.
And you can see the Trajan continues this interest in a ornamentation that was a
characteristic of the Flavian period,
very ornamental architectural decoration,
very deeply carved with a strong contrast between light and dark.
So he does continue this Flavian interest in very elaborate architectural
decoration.
You'll remember that the temple of Venus Ghana tricks in the forum of Julius
Caesar had a pediment that had in the center of that pediment a scene depicting
Venus rising from the sea.
Uh,
and there is other Venus imagery and I show you a detail and it's on your
monument list.
I show you a detail of part of a freeze that depicts a cupid's wing,
had chubby wing,
had babies.
As you can see here,
cupid's who are carrying the arms.
You can see one of them with a sword sheath over here,
they are carrying the arms and armor of Mars,
Mars of course,
the consort of Venus and Mars making reference also to military victory.
Uh,
this freeze as far as we can tell,
does belong to the tray Janick renovation of the building,
but it probably does look back,
uh,
to earlier to an earlier Julian freeze that decorated the original temple in
Rome from this from,
and I use that a restoration of the temple of Venus Ghana tricks in the form of
Julius Caesar as an example of the kind of restoration work that Trajan embarked
on at the beginning of his principle.
But much more important to us today are to building two buildings,
the first a bath and the second a forum that are examples of the devotion that
Trajan had two public architecture during his reign.
And I show you a view here.
In fact,
a plan of the so called baths of Trajan in Rome that were dedicated in
[inaudible] nine.
As you can see from the monument list,
we know the architect in this particular case,
uh,
it is Apollo,
Doris of Damascus,
and his name says a lot about him,
Apollo,
Doris from,
from Damascus,
modern Syria.
Uh,
so it's very interesting.
We have an emperor from Spain and an architect from Syria who worked together.
This is a sign that things are beginning to change in the Roman empire as the
Romans,
as Trajan extends those borders even further.
It brings in an even more multifaceted,
multifaceted civilizations around the world.
Uh,
and talent begins to pour into Rome from all of those places.
Paula Doris of Damascus is,
we'll see today was an extraordinary architect right up there with severance and
Keller and with Riveria Spec,
one could argue even the equal of rebellious.
And what's particularly interesting is that that,
uh,
Apollo doors of Damascus,
like Severus in Keller before him,
appears to have been above all a great engineer.
Uh,
he actually accompanied Trajan on trade gins,
military,
uh,
campaigns,
and served as trade is military architect.
So his first commissions,
we're building bridges.
I'm going to show you a reference to one today,
building bridges or building forts and camps on Trajan is military campaigns.
Uh,
and then,
uh,
using that expertise,
a ingratiating himself with the emperor who sees that he is enormously talented
cause Trajan was on the ruck.
Trajan participated in these campaigns himself,
seeing how talented he was and then putting him in charge of his building
projects in Rome,
which is really quite interesting.
And so these projects are not only aesthetically pleasing and fascinating,
but also show extraordinary,
uh,
engineering skill on the part of the major designer,
namely Apollo,
Doris of Damascus.
Now these bags of Trajan are very interesting in all kinds of ways.
You can already see by looking at the plan,
their location,
they are located on the Eschalon Hill,
uh,
and part of the op Ian Hill,
which I don't think I've mentioned before.
O P P I a n the smaller op Ian Hill and the bads of Titus that,
well,
let me,
let me remind you first that the,
uh,
the Dome is,
our area of Nero was built in part on the Escalade.
Inhale.
And you'll recall the so called Espolon wing,
which is the one wing of Nero's Domus area that is still preserved underground.
Uh,
you'll recall that after Nero's dumb not to your memoria and the coming to power
of the Flavian dynasty that Vespasian and Titus and even demission built,
they're built razed to the ground,
uh,
Nero's buildings.
This patient did that and then he and Titus and emission built new buildings on
top of those and chose to make those buildings the kind of public buildings that
the citizenry as a whole would enjoy.
What from the Coliseum and amphitheater,
uh,
to the baths of Titus.
Uh,
and you see again,
the bads of Titus here located right again on top of this area.
Uh,
that originally belonged to Nero's Domus out Aria Trajan follow suit.
He not only his interest in public architecture like Vespasian and Titus before
him,
but he follows their lead in building these buildings on top of earlier
structures now destroyed,
uh,
of narrow.
So it's again the same message giving back to the people of the land that Nero
had taken illegally,
uh,
from Rome during his reign.
The boughs of Trajan are based in large part on the plan of the Bas of Titus
with some additions.
But you can see the extraordinary difference in scale.
The bads of Titus.
We're not small.
Uh,
and yet the bads of Trajan,
uh,
are at least three,
if not four or more times the size of the bads of Titus.
So this tells us something again about the grandiosity of the vision of Trajan,
about the,
uh,
the funds that he had at his disposal.
And he got those funds in large part because of all these military victories in
which he took all kinds of spoils and booty,
which are used to fund his building campaigns in Rome.
Uh,
and it also tells us something about his ambitions.
Now I don't want you to get the impression that we never had big buildings
before.
You can think back way to the beginning of the semester when we talked about
Julius Caesar and his architecture and his bragging that he had built a a or,
or one of the authors of that period tells us that a Julius Caesar had built a
temple to Mars.
The biggest in the world.
So in its own day it was supposedly the biggest in the world.
Uh,
but we're getting even more ambitious with visa vi scale.
And I think perhaps,
again,
I'm psychoanalyzing Trajan too much,
but I think the fact that this is a man who had the ambitions that he did to
extend the Empire to its furthest reaches seems to go.
It seems to be in keeping with the kind of man who would want to make the
buildings in Rome that he built a kind of microcosm of that hugely expanded
empire.
With regard to the plan of the Bas,
you will see that it follows the so called imperial bath type that was initiated
by the Bas of Titus,
at least with regard to a bas.
It's still prison are still preserved.
I mentioned to you when we talked about the bads of Titus,
there may have been an earlier bath of Nero that actually followed this same
imperial bath form,
but we're not absolutely sure about its plan.
That is the neurone and best they existed,
but we're not absolutely sure about their plan.
But if we look back at the bads of Titus,
you'll remember that what made them distinctive and what made them differ from
the earlier stobby and bas or foreign Basit.
Pompei was the way in which they placed the bathing block in the center rather
than to the side,
uh,
that they arranged the main rooms,
the,
uh,
the tepid Doriam,
the frigging Darian and the call Daria in this case in axial relationship to one
another.
And then all the other rooms of the bath were displayed around those in a
symmetrical way.
So axiology and symmetry reign supreme,
uh,
and then otherwise we saw here the rest of the precinct within elaborate
entrance way over here,
we see roughly the same in the bowels of Trajan in that again,
the bathing block is located right at the center of the structure.
And the main rooms are aligned with one another.
Axially.
If you look up to the,
where it says bas of Trajan,
that at the northern end is the entrance into the baths.
You enter from there into n,
which is in the Tatio or swimming pool,
a PC,
Anna.
Uh,
and then you can see that as surrounded by columns on axis with the swimming
pool is the frigging Doriam at f.
And you can see just like that of the baths of Titus.
It is a groin vaulted room,
a triple groin vaulted room.
As you can see by the three x's over the rectangular area.
Uh,
it has,
uh,
kind of,
an apps or Exedra at the upper most part through which one comes from the
Natacha into the frigate Darian.
And you can see that is screened by columns.
Then from there into the fairly simple rectangularly shaped tepid Darian that
serves more as a kind of passageway from the frigging Darian into C,
which of course is the caldarium or the warmest room,
the sauna of the bas that also has a rectangular shape.
But with these radiating a alcoves radiating alcoves that we're going to see are
screened by columns.
And they are of course facing the southern end where the sun is a and that would
of course help do heat the call caldarium as well.
Uh,
and then what we see,
what we see though with regard to the baths of Trajan that make them differ from
the bads of Titus and a part of this evolution of imperial bath architecture in
Rome,
uh,
is the fact that the bathing block is placed in this very large rectangular
precinct.
Uh,
and this large rectangular precinct has a series of rooms around it.
As you can see real rooms and rooms that take all kinds of shapes.
Many of them are,
uh,
these,
heavy cycle type shapes screen,
uh,
by call from,
with columns from the larger central space.
But some of them also look like the tobacco,
NY,
uh,
that we've become used to in plan.
Uh,
we see all of those there.
And these were used as far as we can determine as meeting halls,
lecture halls,
Greek and Latin library.
So this is this,
this extension of the bath from being just a place where you went to,
to get to,
uh,
you know,
for wellness essentially to,
to bathe and to relax and to have social interaction with your friends.
Uh,
they are adding an intellectual element to the bath buildings.
So you can also go there if you want to read.
If you want to go to the library,
read Greek books,
read Latin books,
go to lectures,
go to seminars,
have conversations.
Intellectual conversations are also beginning to happen here.
So the bath becomes even more a of a Mecca for people who are interested in
intellectual life as well as,
uh,
bathing and social life,
which is a very important development culturally for the Romans.
A note here,
also this great hemi cycle down here,
which is part of the bath building,
a Hemi cycle that had seats on it,
which probably serve four performances of whatever kind,
uh,
that would have taken place here.
So that's another interesting addition to the bathing scene and should remind
you of the kind of Hemi cycles that we saw,
for example,
in the sanctuary or Fortuna premed Jania at Palestrina or the sanctuary of
Hercules at Tivoli w where they also had those performance areas.
So bringing in some of those elements from sanctuary design into a bath design
in the bads of Trajan in Rome,
the bas of Trajan.
Uh,
some parts of them still exist but scattered.
and in fact,
they are located now in a kind of a pleasant garden area.
As you can see here,
this is a Google earth view that shows you their proximity to the coliseum.
We see the edge of the coliseum over here.
So the Eschalon hill in large part a,
and you can just barely make out here.
If you look,
you see this curved wall down here.
That curved wall is in fact that Hemi cycled with the for the theatrical
performances that I showed you just before.
Uh,
and that is actually the entrance where they wouldn't going to Rome over break.
That's actually the entrance to the dome is our area.
If it's open to periodically closes,
sometimes if things are falling down,
but if it's open,
that's how one gets there.
Uh,
and over here,
you can actually see,
this is the,
I may have shown this to you before,
but this is actually,
uh,
the Oculus of the octagonal room of Nero's Domus area.
You can see it if you wander through this park,
you can see it from above with a grate on top of it,
as well as down below if you visit the palace itself.
And then up here you can see another right up above my finger.
You can see another curved wall.
And there's another one somewhere down here,
uh,
that are part of those,
those,
those curved rooms as Hemi Securitas have made cycle shaped rooms that are,
that are,
uh,
these lecture halls and meeting halls and so on.
So,
and actually that one,
the one that's up here,
uh,
actually has,
um,
niches in the wall with shelves,
which indicates to us that that was used as one of the libraries scrolls would
have been placed on those shelves and then have cupboards in front of them.
So one can see remains.
It's made out of concrete,
faced with brick,
one can see remains on the top of that hill.
Uh,
but a model over here,
it gives you a better sense of what it looked like in antiquity,
were again,
looking at that large hemi cycle that served with its seats,
that served four performances.
Here we're looking at the outer precinct wall.
We can see the semi domes of some of the Hemi cycles here.
And we can also see the bathing block,
uh,
at the upper most part,
the entrance way,
the courtyard surrounded by columns,
which is where the pool or Natalia was located.
Uh,
the covered area here was the frigging Darian,
then the test,
the Dar in the Caldari ms here.
And here you can see those radiating alcoves with columns,
uh,
that opened them up,
for vistas and the like,
as well as to the warmth of the sun.
So an incredible bathing,
a establishment,
uh,
and one that has taken us a step further and the evolution of imperial bath
architecture in Rome and will serve as the major model for the two most famous
and much better preserved,
uh,
bads in Rome.
And that is the baths of Caracalla and the bads of Diocletian,
which we'll look at later in the semester.
But I'd like to turn from the tray Janick vads to the unquestionably the most
important public building that was commissioned by Trajan during his reign.
And I can't overemphasize enough the importance of this building in the history
of Roman architecture.
And we're going to see that it is two part in the sense that it has,
it is a forum.
It has the forum proper and it also has markets appended to us.
They are done in a different architectural style.
And Harold,
something very important,
very important development enrollment architecture that's going to be carried
further,
uh,
by,
trade gins,
successors.
The,
what we're looking at here is a spectacular aerial view of the part of Rome in
which the forum of Trajan finds itself.
Uh,
we are looking,
we are looking at buildings that we have looked at before so we can get our
bearings.
This is of course the wedding cake of Victor Emmanuel.
Over here you can see,
uh,
a part of the Oval Piatsa designed by Michelangelo of the comp.
Doleo.
You can also see and what's this down here
forum met Wendy,
the Julian Forum,
the Forum of Julius Caesar,
much lower ground level then the rest of the city today.
And you can actually see those three columns from the temple that I showed you
just before,
as well as the [inaudible] of the Julian Forum.
And note the relationship of the Julian Forum to the tray Janick form.
He's restoring Julius Caesar's forum at the same time he's building his own.
I can also show you here,
uh,
if you look right above my hand,
you can see the Po,
uh,
Piatsa Venezia and the Palazzo Venay Tsia.
If you look at the center of that building right over the doorway,
there's a balcony that is the famous Mussolini Balcony.
That's the balcony from which muscle Leni made all his speeches with his
followers gathering in the pilots have a Naisia.
Uh,
and from that,
from the [inaudible] of the street that goes from there to the Piazza del Popolo
is the Corso,
the race course,
the Corso of Rome,
which is one of the major streets of Rome where the major shopping streets of
Rome,
as well as one of the major thoroughfares that takes you,
if you go down halfway,
take a right,
you were at the via Conn Dottie and ultimately at the Piatsa disbar new or the
Spanish steps,
which of course is a trap that everybody who visits Rome,
uh,
follows that path to see the Spanish steps over here.
The forum that we're going to be talking about today,
the forum of Trajan,
much of that forum is underground.
Uh,
and some of it was turned into a garden.
As you can see here,
pleasant park.
here we are looking at some of the columns from the basilica that's part of that
forum from the very well preserved column of Trajan.
Uh,
and also over here we'll see the markets of the forum.
But I just wanted you to get your bearings again in terms of where it's situated
in Rome and what it looks like today from the air,
although it is changing all the time.
And I wanted to show you a Google earth image as well cause this is much more up
to date than the aerial view that I showed you just before.
Uh,
and you'll see the same buildings.
You'll see the Victor Emmanuel monument,
you'll see part of the company Doleo,
you'll see,
uh,
the,
the muscly and he balcony and the Corso,
uh,
and you'll see the column of Trajan and part of the basilica.
But what you see here is that park has been replaced by structures,
uh,
because they are excavating.
I've mentioned this before,
they,
they are excavating,
uh,
more of this now with the hope of someday rejoining the Roman forum with the
imperial fora that may not be able to happen because of traffic concerns.
But it is certainly something that's on the drawing board.
And at the very least right now without narrowing the street,
the main via day fori and periodically they are doing excavation in that park
area and you can see what they've brought up.
This is not ancient.
It's actually mostly medieval,
uh,
houses.
I hope you felt there.
No medievalism on you,
but I hope they'll eventually realize that these are,
well,
who's to say,
uh,
that,
that they should probably remove these as well.
And take us back to the original forum of Trajan.
I hope that happens.
Somebody,
they're very distinctive if one looks at them,
no,
just mainly rectangular rooms.
Uh,
but nonetheless there at that medieval level now,
and the question is whether they're going to go down any further,
but here you can see not only the remains of the forum of Trajan,
but also the form of Augustus.
Here's the temple of Marzel tour,
that great precinct wall that divided it from the Sabura also visible here.
And here we see the great heavy cycle that we'll look at today of Trajan is
forum behind it,
the markets of Trajan.
It's important for us to look back at the general plan of the imperial fora,
uh,
to see where the forum of Trajan fits in.
We have already looked at the form of Julius Caesar with its Temple of Venus
Gannett tricks.
We have looked at the forum of Augustus with its temple of Mars old tour.
Remember the exact dry on either side of that temple,
the embracing arms that were new at that time,
and an important component of the forum of Augustus Vespasian adds his forum
pacas over here.
Uh,
demission adds a narrow forum,
uh,
the so called forum transitory and that served as a point of transit between the
Roman forum and the Sabura.
Ah,
here it is at,
at that he puts a temple to his patron goddess Minerva,
uh,
in that,
forum.
Uh,
but it is at his death.
It is taken over by Nerva and renamed the Forum of Nerva.
I mentioned to you when we talked about the forum transitory Torian that
demission also had his eye on this property over here.
He had grant,
he has it.
He had his schemes,
his grandiose for public architecture.
At one point as per palatial architecture,
but palatial architecture one out.
And he put all of his effort into the palace on the Palatine Hill and never
realized,
uh,
any construction in this area.
When Trajan became emperor,
he decided that he would would again focus on public architecture and that he
would build a forum like none other before it.
Uh,
and so he begins to do that.
Now,
that was no small feat in this particular part of the city because most of this
area was occupied by a hill.
Uh,
the so called Queer and all Q,
u.
I,
r.
N A,
l,
the queerer knowl hill in Rome occupied most of this space.
So what he needed to do,
it's great to have an architect engineer in your back pocket.
So he set a Pala doors of Damascus to work.
He said,
you're a great engineer.
All you need to do is take down a good part of the queer and the hill to make
way for this great forum that I want to build.
And Lo and behold,
a Pala Doris was absolutely up to the job.
Uh,
and that's exactly what he sets out to do.
He removes 125 feet of the queer all hill in order to make way for the forum of
Trajan.
And that very,
uh,
number 125 feet is actually commemorated in the column of Trajan because the
column of Trajan was built to that very same height,
125 feet to show you as you stand in the forum,
how much of that hill had to be cut back in order to make way for the forum.
You can see by looking at this plan of the imperial for as a whole,
and this is our lead,
not only did trade and take the Empire to its furthest extent,
this is the last forum that was added to the imperial fora in Rome.
Uh,
you can see by looking at it in connection to the others,
that if you count it plus the markets,
which you see wending their way up,
what was left of the queer and they'll hill here in plaid.
If you compare that to the others,
you can see that the forum of Trajan and the markets of Trajan were almost as
large as all of the other fora,
not counting the Roman forum,
but all of the other imperial fora together,
which gives you some sense of why I call this the mother of all forums.
Now we're going to look at the plan of this and I'm going to show you an
individual plan in a moment.
But what I want to say,
well this is still on the screen,
uh,
is that I want you to look at the [inaudible] that you see on either side of the
main space of the forum and on either side of the basilica over here.
These are not coincidentally,
they are certainly meant to make reference to the IG Z dry of Augustus's forum.
Trajan modeled himself after Augustus.
He became a kind of neo Augustus.
He,
uh,
took on Augustus is hairstyle and his manners and so he was trying to associate
himself in his life with Augustus.
He's doing it here also through architecture by placing those exceed dry on
either side of his forum.
Here's the plan of the forum itself.
On the left hand side of the screen where we can see all of its major features,
you'd enter into the forum down here.
Uh,
there was a very elaborate entrance way here and you can see that the,
the facade is actually not straight but convex,
convex,
a convex facade,
which is very interesting curved facade,
uh,
with an elaborate entrance way over here,
the entrance into the main part of the forum,
rectangular in shape.
There's a base here for an equestrian statue of Trajan,
the exceed dry on either side,
mimicking those of the forum of Augustus colonnades,
also on either side and some additional columns here.
And we're going to see that just as an Augustus's forum.
Another reference back to Augustus that the columns in this main area,
our Corinthian below,
but in the second tier there are figures,
not figures of Karrie audits,
but different kinds of figures.
And I'm going to show you those soon over here,
the basilica,
which is perpendicular to the forum proper,
this is quite different from the forum at palm pay where you'll remember the
basilica was splayed off to the side.
Here we have it as a more integral part of the forum and perpendicular to the
main space here.
It's a very large basilica.
It takes the name of Trajan,
his family,
his family name was opiates.
You LP,
I.
U.
S.
This is the Basilica Olympia in Rome with a central nave and side aisles,
a couple of side aisles around it or veritable forest of columns.
And then other exceed dry matching exceeds our er in this case apses on either
end.
Then through here you see the location of the column of Trajan in a small,
uh,
small,
Piatsa and to left and right libraries,
Greek and Latin libraries.
And then at the end of temple,
we don't know what Trajan actually the,
the,
the temp,
the northern end of the structure was not completed at trade is death.
And we don't know if he would have put a temple there.
It's highly likely because what forum have we seen without a temple at the short
end,
they all had them,
so it's a good guests.
Uh,
the Trajan had that in mind too,
but the temple that was built there was actually built after his death by his
successor Hadrian a temple that Hadrian put up to honor Trajan and also trade
Jin's wife,
Palatine of PLO,
t I n a.
Now we know quite a bit,
a lot of the forum,
some of the forum is still preserved.
Uh,
and we have evidence for other parts of it that are not preserved.
This entrance gate down here,
believe it or not,
we have coins,
uh,
that have an entrance gate on them and nicely they say,
fortunately they say down below forum,
try on forum of Trajan.
So putting two and two together,
uh,
we have to go on the assumption that what we are looking at here is a rendition
on a coin of the entrance gate into the forum of Trajan Forum.
Uh,
and if we look at it here,
we see some interesting things.
We see first of all that it has a single occupation in the center.
So one doorway,
it has a series of bays that have in them,
uh,
what we call Idig,
July a,
l a,
e I udicky July,
uh,
which are little temple,
little temple fronts that are niches with little temple fronts around them with
columns and pediments.
And then you can see statuary inside those.
So a series of bays decorated with these [inaudible] with statutes,
then a series of circles with blobs in them.
I think those series of circles with blobs in them are probably the,
uh,
portraits represented on shields because we have act,
we have remains of actual portraits on shields from the inside of the forums.
So that seems to be the case here as well.
And then in the upper most part,
we see that the,
the gate,
uh,
it looks very much like an arch and the sense that it supports a quad rigor at
the top.
And that quad rigor represents two people,
possibly the emperor.
Again,
we're dealing with blobs here.
We have to do the best we can to interpret them.
Uh,
but they seem to be probably the emperor and possibly victory.
Crowning him the way we saw victory crowning Titus in his chariot on his arch,
six horses in this particular case.
And then on either side trophies,
these tree trunks decorated with captured arms and armor.
Uh,
and uh,
prob we're not absolutely sure what surrounding them in this case,
whether they're prisoners or Roman soldiers.
So this gives you a very good idea of the entrance gate into this structure.
And I also want to point out if you look very closely at the columns and the
elements above them in the attic,
you can see that the columns project and the addict seems to have projecting and
tablature.
So it looks as if we have the kind of scheme here that we saw in the form,
transitory them with that wall decorated with columns that project out of the
wall and that have projecting and tablature giving this undulation Mu undulating
movement from projecting to receiving,
projecting to receiving across the facade of the entrance gate,
the figures that were located on the upper tier of the center of the main body
of this forum.
Again,
we're not carry odds are female figures,
but rather male figures,
male figures of captured dations because the war,
uh,
that Trajan,
had that enabled him to fuck to celebrate and to fund this building was his wars
against the dations Dac.
I a n s Daysha ancient Dacia Modern Romania today Trajan had to military
campaigns there.
One from one oh two,
two one oh two one.
Oh,
excuse me.
The first one from one a one two,
one oh two,
the second one from one oh five,
two,
one oh seven.
He was victorious in both of those.
Uh,
and he,
uh,
he,
this forum was built from the spoils of that war to honor his victory.
Over the dations.
Uh,
and we see therefore that the figures that are in the upper most tier of the
main body of the form are depictions of captured a dations updation prisoners,
uh,
brought back to Rome.
You see two of them here,
here,
a headless figure here,
a much more complete figure.
The headless figure is still at,
can be seen on the site and the one on the left hand side of the screen now in
the Vatican museums in Rome,
and the one on the left gives you a better sense of what these looked like in
antiquity.
You can tell that these are not Romans wearing leggings,
a tunic,
a fringed mantle that the Romans did not wear a,
a long fringe mantle.
And then above you see that he has a,
unlike Trajan closely clopped Agus cropped a Gustin type hairstyle.
You can see he has very long hair,
uh,
and also a beard.
And this,
this identifies him as a very different in Denton for sort of,
um,
uh,
boots.
It seemed to be made out of Suede or felt of some sorts.
So a very different kind of image.
Clearly,
uh,
these are again,
the Dacian prisoners,
one after another,
uh,
aligning that second tier.
And for any of you interested in the fact that the Romans made nearly exact
duplicates of things,
mechanical copies,
uh,
you can see in this particular statute,
we rarely have this preserved.
So it's an interesting example,
uh,
of these points who see these little x excess pieces of marble.
Uh,
the Romans had created a kind of pointing machine,
which they use to make a exact replicas of originals.
Uh,
and they usually,
when the statue was done,
they would usually obviously,
uh,
take these away.
I mean carved them away,
which they didn't do.
This one probably was not used for some reason it was copied and never put up on
the building.
And so those points still remain.
This is a model of the forum of Trajan,
uh,
as it would've looked in antiquity with that convex entrance way.
The location of the equestrian statue of the [inaudible] dry on either side.
Here you can imagine they dations and the second tier,
uh,
the roofed basilica,
Olivia here,
the column of Trajan flagged by the Latin and Greek libraries.
And then over here,
uh,
the temple to Divine Trajan the plan again.
Uh,
and uh,
here we can hear,
I just want to mention looking back at that plan that there was also a,
another elaborate entrance way from the main part of the forum into the Basilica
Olivia on its long side.
And once again,
how fortunate we are that we have a co have coins it say basilica,
Olympia,
basilica opiate.
So we can guess,
I think quite accurately that this must be the entrance way to the basilica
opiate.
Here we see something different.
We see three openings,
not RQ weighted openings,
but Trey be aided,
opening straight lentils above.
But look again in the way in which they're represented.
It looks like they're quite solid and that they project into the spectators
space.
So again,
this idea of projection,
recession,
projection,
recession across this facade,
this is very important because as I mentioned,
uh,
Roman architecture using the traditional language of Greek architecture
ultimately developed something that we call a baroque trend in Roman
architecture.
And you see it happening here in Rome based on the experiments of de Missions
Forum trends a Tortilla.
And you can see that same roughly that same scheme here up above,
once again a chariot and this case a four horse chariots seemingly with one
figure and a series of standards being hold held possibly by Roman soldiers.
Uh,
the,
uh,
the forum of Trajan has been the professional,
the,
the life work of a professor,
uh,
formerly of the Northwestern University James Packer,
who spent a very long time pulling together all the evidence that the forum of
Trajan still provides to allow a very good reconstruction of what that forum
looked like.
It's computer generated.
I urge you all to look at it.
If you just,
if you just Google James Packer Forum of Trajan Ucla because that's the tower
the Getty,
uh,
either of those two cause Ucla and the Getty supported this work,
you will be able to see computer simulations of,
uh,
of his work.
Uh,
there's also a book by James Packer on the forum of Trajan that's on reserve for
this course.
I send you to it less for the forum of Trajan,
but for any of you working on city plans,
again,
this could be a very inspiring a book to look at it.
Not that I expect you to come up with something like this.
Uh,
but nonetheless,
I think it can give you an idea of what one can do.
As one thinks about designing one own city.
He has,
he has done enough research to allow a very accurate reconstruction of what this
forum would have looked like.
We're looking at the entrance way into the basilic Olivia here.
Uh,
we are looking at,
uh,
the marble.
You can see real marble and very gated marbles brought them all over the world.
So Trajan continues the Flavian tradition of bringing marbles from all over,
from places outside of Italy,
from Africa,
from Asia Minor,
uh,
from Egypt and so on for the decoration of these buildings and an interest in
multicolored marbles as facing we see also up here the Dacian prisoners and
between them in this instance,
these shields,
uh,
with portraits on them,
we have remains of some of those.
That's an accurate reconstruction.
The same sort of thing that we saw on the entrance way.
Then up there and inscription,
some,
several other dations and uh,
some other decoration at the apex.
I'm going to show you just a few of these quickly from Packer's book.
Uh,
you see here a Carter with a barrel vault,
a stuccoed and painted lots of statuary.
That would have been lots of honorific statuary,
uh,
in this structure.
Sometimes instead of the shields with portraits between the dations,
we see piles of captured arms and armor.
As you can see in that view.
A here,
a couple more showing again,
the marble decoration of the walls,
a very varied,
varied in color here.
Uh,
niches with portraits over here,
more shields with portraits.
And here you can see some of the sculptural remains us,
some parts of a,
of a breath,
a military figure in a breast plate,
a man,
both of them headless,
uh,
in a toga and over here,
part of one of these decorative shields with a,
a portrait.
We actually think this is a portrait of nerva portrait of nerve that would have
been placed inside the shield and hung on the upper part of the wall above the
columns.
And this,
this is a important and on your list,
this is a view of the Basilica Olympia in Rome.
What it would have looked like in antiquity.
You can see it conforms to Basilican architecture that we've looked at before
with a central nave,
a divided by two by it's two side aisles in this case,
as you'll recall in plan.
Uh,
and uh,
those are Corinthian capitals as you can see down here.
Uh,
you can see also that it's a,
it's a Gargantuan structure.
Look at the size of the,
of the people in the men in their togas and the building itself.
And it had a flat roof with a coffered ceiling.
And you can see that it had a clear story.
We've talked about the clear story before we saw it in the house of the Mosaic
Atrium,
for example,
the clear story,
which is the opening up of the wall,
uh,
in this case,
through a ionic columns to see the vistas that lie beyond and to let light into
the structure.
And you can see the vista that lies beyond is the column of Trajan and one of
the libraries.
This is a,
uh,
a photograph that I'm incredibly proud of because I took it from on top of the
column of Trajan.
Uh,
it's not that difficult to climb the column of Trajan cause there's a spiral
staircase in the center of it that goes up to the top.
The part,
the part that's hard is getting permission to get in there.
It's always locked and you have to get special permission to do that.
So I did it only once,
but it was a great thing to do.
And you go way up to the top and you can look down,
you can see fantastic views of Rome,
uh,
but you can also get a very good sense of what the basilica opiate looks like
today.
Uh,
and not much.
but you can see the central space.
You can see some of the columns.
We can tell that those columns were gray granite.
So again,
this interest in contrasting marbles,
Greg rounded with white marble in the basilica opiate and elsewhere.
And you can also see the relationship between modern ground level,
which is much higher and ancient ground level and the possibilities that still
remain if they want to excavate this part of the city.
What more of the forum of Trajan may be able to be seen.
Some of it can actually be seen under the street and packer and others have
actually gone in to look at what is there,
which is what has enabled him to make the kind of accurate reconstructions that
he has everywhere in this monument.
There are references,
yes,
this is a forum.
Yes,
forums have practical purposes,
their place to,
uh,
to,
um,
for people to meet and to market and to,
uh,
conduct law cases and so on in the basilica.
But this monument reminds you again and again and again and again that it is a,
uh,
a monument in stone to Trajan victories over the dations.
And not only do we see those stations as we looked at before,
but we see lots of other imagery that refers to military victory.
This is a fragment of what we think was a freeze in the Basilica Olympia that
depicts victories,
female personifications of victory wing.
It,
uh,
either kneeling at candelabra or overhear this woman kneeling on the back of a
bull.
Uh,
you can see that she's whinging and she's holding the snout of that bull back.
She's got a knife in her right hand and she is about to slit the throat of the
bull.
Uh,
and she is doing this to not only to not only his victory over the dations being
marked here,
uh,
but she is also representing the sacrifice that takes place in honor of that
victory,
uh,
by uh,
being shown,
uh,
depicting a killing a bull back to the plan.
Once again,
just to remind you that when we leave the Basilica Olympia doorway,
also in its long side,
we end up in this small plaza where the temple,
where the column of Trajan is located,
flanked by Greek and Latin libraries on axis with the equestrian statue on axis
with the entrance way,
the equestrian statue of Trajan,
the other entrance way the column,
and ultimately the temple at the very end,
the temple ultimately to divine Trajan.
This a model of what we think the library may have looked like,
or both of the library's may have looked like from the outside,
fairly smallish a square buildings with a portico in the front.
And then most important,
uh,
a balcony over here.
Why a balcony so that you could come out and look at the column of Trajan and
read some of the scenes that in circled it.
This is a reconstruction from packer,
again,
showing what he thinks the interior of one of these libraries might've looked
like.
It looks larger here than it actually was a,
but you can get a sense of it with the reading tables,
with the scrolls inside these cabinets here.
Uh,
with the statuary and in this case he believes that it had a vaulted roof.
As you can see,
a top,
the column of Trajan,
you see it here in two views,
uh,
an extraordinary work of art,
extremely WellPreserved.
Why so well preserved?
Well likely because pope sixth is the fifth and the renaissance,
uh,
use this column and also the column of the later Emperor Marcus Aurelius as
important nodes in his reconstruction of the city of Rome at what he did.
However,
at that time was that he took the statues of Trajan,
uh,
that would have stood on this one.
And Marcus are really is on the other and replaced them with statues of Peter
and Paul.
And it's Peter who's on the column of Trajan and Paul who was on the column of
Marcus Aurelius.
But you can see how well preserved they are here.
The column shaft rests on a base decorated with arms and armor dation arms and
armor with ultimate,
you know,
with a statue of Trajan up at the,
uh,
bronze statue of Trajan at the upper most part.
But what's particularly interesting is the sculpture.
I'm not going to go into that in great detail,
but I want you to know about it because it does tell us something about
architecture as we'll see.
It's a spiral freeze done all in marble of course,
that from the base of the column all the way up to the top and it tells in
documentary form,
uh,
the exploits,
the military exploits of Trajan in his two day [inaudible] military campaigns.
Uh,
his,
he's those two campaigns that I've already mentioned divided in the center by a
victory writing on a shield,
a one,
there's been a lot of speculation.
There's nothing like this earlier,
enrollment art quite like this.
Uh,
and so it is a new innovation probably at the behest of Po pop,
possibly out of the mind,
the creative mind of Apollo,
Doris of Damascus and sculpt.
Some scholars have suggested and I think very convincingly,
it's an intriguing idea that because this was located between two libraries,
the likelihood and that the Romans had scrolls,
the likelihood is what we are dealing here with here is one of these scrolls or
sort of wrapped around the column from base to top a unfurled and wrapped around
the column from base to top with the text removed with images instead of text.
Uh,
and that,
that makes a lot of sense.
Again,
given that you could view it most best from the two libraries on either side,
a detail of the base,
just to show you how very well preserved the sculptural decoration is.
This is not a course in sculpture.
I'm not going to go into this in detail,
but I want to quickly show you some of the scenes because again,
they can be revealing from the point of view of architecture.
This is at the very base.
We see a personification of the Danube River,
uh,
in that area up north in Daisha where the Romans went to conquer those tribes.
Uh,
and you,
and this is very important because we know that Apollo doors of Damascus was
responsible for building a bridge over the Daniel Bridge River.
It was one of his great engineering feats.
And you actually see that bridge,
uh,
located here,
which even increases the likelihood that Apollo doors of Damascus was the
designer of this particular structure.
You see,
the Roman soldiers have gotten off boats.
They're walking through a,
a,
an archway.
Here you see the Roman soldiers,
the Roman soldiers did not only do battle,
uh,
but they also,
romanized the areas that they want.
We've talked about this a lot.
The colonization of the Roman world.
Trajan extending the borders to their furthest,
most points.
The Romans get there.
What do they do?
They start to build architecture.
They start to build walls with Heteros and stretchers.
They start to build a forts,
uh,
and,
and city walls and which they put buildings with Roman amenities.
Remember,
after wars,
after the war is over,
they're often given land by the general or the emperor,
uh,
to,
to the becomes theirs and where they can live from that point on.
So they had every reason to want to,
uh,
fill these towns with Roman amenities.
And we see the Roman soldiers building cities in many of these scenes.
This is the most famous scene from the column in which we see a battle between
the Romans inside one of these sports that they've built a,
they are all with helmets and shields.
They have their hands around something.
We think these were probably spears that were added in metal originally.
The dations down below.
You can identify them by their leggings and tunics and scraggly hair and beards
here.
Uh,
they are attacking the camp.
The Romans are of course going to be victorious,
but the nations are shown as heroic and Valliant and,
and enemies who are pretty much the equals of the Roman and Romans and strength,
which only underscores that the Romans were stronger still to have conquered
them.
Uh,
and then over here,
if you've ever wondered where the term battering Ram came from,
you can see it right here.
Told you the Romans invented everything.
Uh,
you can see it right here.
This pole with a Ram said at the end,
which is a serving again as a battering ram as they try to tear down the walls
of the Roman fort.
Uh,
prob perhaps the most poignant and interesting scene happens way up at the top
of the column where the leader of the nation's dissemble as e e B a l u s is
shown kneeling,
almost like one of those victories on the,
uh,
on the bowl.
Uh,
he has a,
uh,
a knife in his hand.
What is he doing?
He is kneeling here.
He has decided,
you can see the Romans.
He's got Romans to the left of him,
Romans to the right of him.
He's about to be taken prisoner by them and paraded in a triumphal procession
and Rome,
uh,
in honor of Trajan.
He doesn't want to do that.
So he heroically,
valiantly takes his own life.
He is about to plunge that knife into his heart,
uh,
so that he doesn't have to be taken by the Romans.
It's very interesting to see them,
uh,
depicting the Romans depicting the dations in such a,
in such a heroic way.
On this column,
I mentioned the museum in Rome that is located in ar,
the Museo della achievable.
Tell Romana the Museum of,
uh,
of Roman civilization that has casts and models.
I mentioned that they had casts of all the scenes from the column of Trajan.
I show you a view that I took in that museum just to give you a sense of how one
can see those and how one can see those at eye's level.
Uh,
to get a good sense of them.
In antiquity,
they would have been harder to read,
but I should point out that the background was likely painted blue and there
probably would have been some additions like the metal spears that might have
made it easier to read.
Almost like Wedgewood might've made it easier to read,
uh,
in antiquity.
And I also thought I would mention,
I'm sure all of you have been down to ground zero,
but if you go a block or two away from ground zero itself,
there's a fireman's memorial there that was put up to many of the fireman who
sadly lost their lives fighting those fires in the twin towers.
Uh,
we see this here dedicated to those who fell into those who carry on a here.
And what's interesting about this,
if you look at,
if you Google this and look at the website for the fireman's memorial in Rome,
in,
uh,
New York,
you will find out that the designer for this talks unabashedly of his admiration
for the column of Trajan in Rome,
and that he used as an artistic model of for the way in which he masked figures
here,
showing them in relationship to buildings he used as his model.
Uh,
the figures on the column of Trajan in Rome at the end.
Again,
the column,
uh,
surrounded by the Greek and Latin libraries.
The temple over here at the end,
you can see it's a conventional Roman temple,
deep porch,
freestanding columns,
uh,
staircase,
one staircase facade orientation.
Just as we saw,
uh,
elsewhere,
here we see an engraving showing the,
uh,
the spiral staircase that leads from bottom to top and overhear that the
staircase also goes down below,
uh,
into a burial chamber.
Two urns were found in that burial chamber,
the urns of Trajan and Platina,
which tells us of course,
that this also served as Trojans tonight.
So victory not only his grit,
one of his great victories,
military victories,
but also victory over death.
And then at the apex we see a good view of the top with a statue of Saint Peter,
but we have coins,
uh,
depicting a Trajan,
on,
uh,
but depicting the original statue,
the base,
the Shaft Co,
a portrait of Trajan,
uh,
naked portrait of Trajan [inaudible] portrait of Trajan depicted after death.
Divinized at the apex of the column.
And if you read the inscription on the coin,
you see it refers to Trajan as Optimas,
pring caps,
phage and received many titles.
One was docie costs DAC,
ICU,
s for his victories over the nations,
but at the end of his life,
optimists print gaps,
the greatest prank ups of all time,
the implication greater than Augustus.
And it is arguable,
I think probably correct that Trajan was the even greater of the two.
This is a restored view.
It is spectacular,
restored view of the building complex where you can see again the entrance way
over here,
the equestrian statue,
everything that we've described.
But I think it's interesting if you think of yourself having entered into this
forum,
standing here,
looking back at the basilica,
bearing trades,
his name,
looking toward the column and the temple.
What you would have likely seen when you stood here was only the upper most part
of the column because most of it would have been blocked by the very tall
Basilica Olympia.
So it's a very theatrical representation in the sense that you would be,
uh,
you know,
standing here with Trajan during life.
Looking back toward that column,
looking back at the divinization of,
of Trajan bronze statue,
which would have seemed as if it was floating on top of the basilic old.
And this is a very dramatic Tablo,
uh,
created here by Apollo,
Doris of Damascus.
And I think it was not equal equal until the 17th century by architects like
John Lorenzo Bernini who also created such spectacular Tableau's.
A,
just to show you again,
the location of the markets of Trajan in relationship to the forum of Trajan.
While the mark,
while the forum was the Romans imposing a rectangular plan on nature,
remember they have to cut back the hill to make way for it.
The markets are something quite different.
They are the Romans accepting the shape of the remaining queer and mill hill and
allowing the shape of that hill to determine,
uh,
the irregular shape of the markets,
the markets,
uh,
unlike the,
the,
a forum that is made out of marble for the most part,
as we've seen very gated marble.
The markets are made out of concrete,
faced with brick,
a very different material,
but a material that is absolutely appropriate when you want to cover a hillside
with tiered buildings.
Looking back very much to the spot by a,
looking back to the Fortuna premed Jania at Palestrina,
the same idea to change,
to turn this hill,
what remained of the queer and hill into essentially the precursor of the modern
shopping mall.
You have shopping.
There are 150 shops,
uh,
in the markets of Trajan.
Uh,
the,
all of these things,
date by the way to the same period around Aidy one 13,
the forum and also the markets.
Uh,
we see 150 shops here on a variety of levels.
This is the bottom level that is located where the [inaudible] are.
The first Exedra is on the right side,
a great hemi cycle with shops.
Uh,
here,
a street called the via Bieber Radhika.
That name is on your monument list.
And then a covered bazaar,
a up here,
all of this on different levels.
All of this done in a very innovative way with concrete faced with brick.
Uh,
you can also see here the very large windows is semi dome that I'll show you in
detail in a moment.
These large windows indicate to us that the architects are real masters of the
concrete medium here,
able to dematerialize,
uh,
the,
wall by,
uh,
putting up these very,
very large one does.
That's how good they were in building this.
At this point.
The,
the,
the building block here is essentially the to bear,
not,
not unlike what we saw in Pompei,
uh,
this small a space with a barrel vault and attic window above.
And in this case with,
uh,
a post and lintel,
a scheme made out of travertine to mark the entrance way into the shop.
They took this individual,
um,
motif and they replicated it throughout this building over and over and over
again,
offering 150 possibilities.
Here you see a series of these in a row series of these to bear and I with their
attic.
When does with their travertine decoration with their sidewalks,
a kind of mini city within a city.
And then over here,
the polygonal masonry of the streets looking very much like streets in Rome.
Here is a view of the great hemi cycle down on the first story,
see the shops again.
What's interesting here is in the second story,
you see RQ weighted elements.
You can see the con,
the facing with the brick facing.
Although we do believe this was stuccoed over in this case here,
pilasters but look very carefully.
You will see these pilasters support in the center and RQ weighted pediment and
then on either side,
these broken triangular pediments as if the pediment has broken,
been broken to allow the uh,
the Rq weighted pediment to show through.
We have never seen that before.
Yes,
we saw it in the paper topics,
but that's stuff is later.
We have not seen that up to this point chronologically in built architecture.
We have seen it in painting curriculum at the met over here for example,
this breaking the triangular pediment to allow something else to show through.
This is the beginning of this experimentation that ultimately leads to this
baroque element in Roman architecture that I'm going to talk about behind the
semi a semi heavy cycle annular bolt with an additional set of shops and attic
windows,
uh,
there as well.
This is the most famous street,
uh,
from the forum,
from the markets of Trajan stuff.
Incredible place to wander by the way.
And they have just recently in the last couple of years,
opened an entirely new museum here,
which has a lot of remains from the forum and from the markets.
And a great deal of very useful information and absolute must see for anyone
going to Rome,
this is the famous via be burrata Berakah of the markets of Trajan where again,
you get the sense once you're in here that you're in a kind of city within a
city.
Uh,
but with all these wonderful shops,
uh,
you can see how skilled they are in using ramps with polygonal masonry as well
as sidewalks and stairs so that you can make your way up with either
alternatives here again that to bear I on either side,
the opening up of the walls with these incredible windows throughout a restored
view of what the whole thing looked like in antiquity,
the Hemi Cycle,
uh,
that the,
the uh,
the decoration here of the central RQ weighted pediment broken triangular
pediments over here,
a very interesting space that I'm going to show you in a second.
Bolted with a semi dome done out of concrete with very large windows opening up
the space via Bieber Radhika that we already saw here.
And then the covered bazaar up there.
Quick view of the semi dome made out of concrete.
It doesn't have an Oculus,
but otherwise it looks kind of like the,
uh,
the dome of the Temple of Mercury at Baia.
As you can see and overhear this wall that I've already described that shows you
how well the Romans can work concrete now,
enabling them to open up the wall,
uh,
much more than they've been able to do so before and allow even more light into
the structure.
The greatest part perhaps of the markets of Trajan is this a building here?
It's the covered bazaar and it really is a market bizarre on two tiers.
You can see in this restored view,
the series of to bear and I down below the attic up above,
you can see the groin vaults are used here in an incredible way.
I'll show you in a moment how a second story appear with additional to bear
night opened almost completely to the sky.
An incredible feat on the part of Apollo doors of Damascus,
assuming he also designed these markets.
Here is the market hall as it looks today.
What is his ancestor,
uh,
the Ferintino market hall that we saw way back when with its single barrel bolt
or some of the Crypto Porticos is that we also saw with their barrel vaults.
It's that idea,
that market hall idea,
but look how sophisticated the Romans had become in their use of concrete.
Faced with brick,
they have realized that they don't even need a wall to support bolts.
They can lift their vault on top of individual peers as they have done so
spectacularly here.
Lift them up.
I described this,
I think in the introductory level lecture is in a sense opening up a series of
umbrellas over the space.
They have opened it up,
uh,
so that light can flow in from the sides.
Like can flow in from uh,
from either long end,
uh,
just flooding the whole system with light down below.
Again,
the typical markets with their,
with their,
uh,
attic windows above.
But this is a real tour de force,
probably the greatest,
certainly the greatest bolting,
uh,
that we have seen thus far.
And again,
a test to just how far the Romans have come from this to this by the time of the
Emperor Trajan and any of you headed to San Francisco.
Uh,
if you go to the,
um,
to the marketplace there,
you will see that that owes so much to Roman antiquity with all the tobacco and
I like structures on either side,
the vaulting,
I mean,
it's this sort of thing absolutely presupposes a,
this kind of architectural development in the one minute that remains.
And that's all I need for this.
I just wanted to show you one last monument and make one basic point about it
that really has more to do with the transition from Trajan Hadrian than anything
else.
Uh,
and arch went up in,
not in Rome but in a place called Ben Aventa,
which is about an hours drive from,
uh,
from Naples,
in the south of Italy and Campania place called Ben event,
or an arch went up between one 14 to one 18 honoring Trajan and all of Trajan is
accomplishments.
You can see it's covered with sculpture.
And each of those scenes represents one of the accomplishments of Trajan.
It was put up on the so called via try Ana taking Trojans name,
uh,
a road that was built from Rome to Ben Event,
and was opened during trade,
gins,
rain,
and again,
a compendium of all his accomplishments.
You can see very clearly that is based in general form on the arch of Titus in
Rome,
the single central RQ weighted bay.
The pedestals are supporting double columns on either side.
The inscription at the top,
the receding,
a receding panels on either side of that inscription.
The major difference of course between the two,
that this has sculpture only on the inside and sparingly in the center and
around the frieze.
And this has much more sculpture,
again,
telling us in much greater detail,
a,
a list or describing a list of the great accomplishments of Trajan.
The main reason that I show it to you today besides to show that the,
the,
that the Flavi is again served Flavian architecture served as an important
model,
uh,
for,
Trey Janick architecture is that a couple of the scenes in the,
uh,
in the attic above are very interesting.
And tell us something about the succession.
Hey Trey.
Hey,
Hadrian does not appear in the lower part of the arch in any of the scenes,
but he appears in two of the scenes and the upper most part,
which is lead scholars.
I think rightly to conclude that the arch was finished up to the,
to the attic before Trayvon's death and that Hadrian finished it.
And what did he do?
He put his own portrait up there with Trajan.
Why was he motivated to do that?
Well,
he had many ego as we'll see when we talk about Hadrian's architecture.
But more than that,
it had something to do with the succession.
We know that Trajan died on August 8th in 117 and we know that on August 8th,
he had no successor officially chosen.
Platina his wife was cray.
She had no children of around,
which is crazy about Hadrian very much his sponsor and wanted to see him
succeed.
Trajan it's likely the Trajan had the same idea in mind,
but it's a little strange because wouldn't he then have adopted him before his
death?
Why would he have waited?
Uh,
but Platina decide.
She consults with advisor.
She said,
we're not going to announce Trojans death.
We're going to keep it a secret.
Uh,
tomorrow we're going to announce the Trajan has adopted Hadrian that happens on
August 9th.
Uh,
and then it was only on the 11th,
that 11th of August that Trajan death was announced to the public.
So some Hanky panky was going on behind the scenes,
but whoever made the choice,
whether it was traded himself or Platina,
uh,
he,
they made a great choice.
Hadrian and extraordinary,
extraordinary emperor as well.
And the point that I,
the one point that I want you to hold and keep with you over break and bring
back,
uh,
when we,
when we get back together and talk,
when we get back together about the Pantheon and Hadrian's villa actively,
the main point that I want you to keep in mind is what we learned from the forum
of Trajan.
And that is that Trajan combined in an incredible way with the help of a Paula
Doris traditional architecture in the form of the forum with it's marble marble
columns and the like an innovative Roman architecture in the form of the brick,
the brick face,
concrete market brought those together in one building in a way that is very
different from anything we've seen up to this point.
And we're going to see that Hadrian keeps that tradition alive,
not only in the Pantheon but also in his villa of Tivoli.
Take care.
Good,
good spring break to everybody.